slavs today are the largest in the
European ethno-linguistic group in
Europe their native today in Central and
Eastern Europe the Balkans and Hall of
North Asia all today Slav speak a
variation of the Slavic language which
comes from the belt O Slavic language
group today Slavs divide themselves into
three main categories mostly according
to historical cultural and language
differences there are Western Slavs
which are Poland Czech Republic Slovakia
South Slavs or the Balkans Slavs are
Slovenia Croatia Bosnia and Herzegovina
Serbia Montenegro the former Yugoslavia
public of Macedonia and Bulgaria and
last two Eastern Slavs are Belarus
Ukraine and Russia early slavic history
is very much shrouded in a mystery as
there are very few first hand written
records in existence and the ones that
do exist are very hard to interpret
due to these nebulous written records
many nationalistic Slavic Germanic and
Hungarian historians from the 18th to
the 21st century interpret them in ways
beneficial to their country oftentimes
contradicting each other's works so I
will try my best to decipher the most
unbiased possible origins of the Slavs
the earliest arguable written records of
the Slavs have been during the late 6th
century BCE Herodotus mentioned the nura
tribe living north of the most northern
city and farmers FASTA history river
mentioning that they came to those lands
from an unknown area due to being driven
out by large serpents and that they were
very ritualistic turning into and acting
like wolves during the ceremonies there
are several ways the source had been
interpreted by historians some say that
nura are clearly a different tribe from
the Scythian as if they were in
Herodotus wouldn't point out that they
lived north of decisions and therefore
they have to be in early protists lovak
or even proto Balto slavic tribe quick
sidenote here in the Baltic and Slavic
languages share a similar linguistic
ancestor and therefore we know there had
to have been some kind of a proto Balto
Slavic tribes somewhere at some point
however we have no idea where how and to
some extent when these two tribes
divided and became two separate language
groups so it might as well been that the
6th century BCE newer tribe could have
been this / - about the slavic tribe
before their division but I digress most
historians and linguist argued that nuri
where a celtic tribe that slavic
these two points that many celtic
settlements were found during that time
in the area described by Herodotus and
that there is no more written or
archaeological linguistic evidence of
Slavic tribes
in the area before the 5th century CE II
the problem with archaeological argument
how is a proto Slavic Celtic and
Scythian tribes are archaeologically
very similar and could be easily
interchangeable on many occasions
therefore knowing for sure that the
archaeological finds in the Nuri area
are Celtic is very unlikely leaving the
debate still open another possible
argument is that the people we call
Citians are a combination of multiple
tribes that we have put into the same
grouping just because they inhabited the
same area and in fact some of the tribes
in the Scythian grouping might be proto
Slavic tribes with the newer being proto
Baltic this would make a geographical
sense but this is not supported by a DNA
study conducted which concluded that
Citians were just to be in a connection
between the Eastern European tribes and
the central and southern Asian tribes
russell nuri weren't the only tribe in
the area that has been characterized as
a slavic or proto slavic tribe their
word is a Tobias which lived in the
southern Poland around 200 BCE to 200 C
the chain Yaakov which lived in northern
Baltic Slavic lands etc although all of
these tribes can be found to have some
similarities with the Slavic tribes
there are no definitive Slavic
archaeological finds in the area and
therefore we cannot say for certain
whether these were proto Slavic people
or just tribes or the Slavs copied some
ideas from when they came into the area
the most likely a scenario is that Nuri
and all the other tribes before around
the 5th century CE were just one of many
Celtic or later Germanic tribes which
inhabited the area of today's Slavs at
one point or another between the 6th
century BCE at the 5th century CE e is
further supported by the fact that
during the invasion of the Huns and the
voice said Tracy there are no mentions
of Slavic tribes coming into contact
with hunts which if the Slavs would have
been in the area already mentioned as
Slavic lands would be inevitable this
means that the Slavs most likely came
into the area after the who neck
political decline not before it is also
believed that some who Nick and other
known Sabich tribes in Central and
Eastern Europe were assimilated into the
Slavic tribes over the upcoming years
the earliest undeniable mention of the
Slavs and with markers was by procopius
a historian under Emperor Justinian in
the 6th century CE II mentions three
main tribes living in all the lands
north of the East River the vanadis Club
ne and antis he says that they worship
only one God the god of lightning but
they are not particularly very religious
he also says that they choose their
leader
mechanically and are tall with brown
hair but lack any kind of hygiene he
also mentions that the tribes live in
Hoonah character which may support the
unique assimilation story but most
likely just means that they never live
in one place for a long time and
probably travel around their lands last
mentions is that they come to battle
mostly naked and that even though they
are differing tribes they all speak the
similar tongue and can understand each
other
this first undeniable mention of Slavs
gives us only one paragraph about their
culture and style of living but it's
still way too little to determine any
close facts about the political state
that the Slavs might have set up in
Europe from the 6th century CE
appearance of Slavs on the historical
stage for the next three centuries they
will expand to the lands they largely
occupied to this day and will also be
divided from the homogeneous group they
used to be into the Slavic divisions of
Western Southern and Eastern Slavs we
know today hopefully this was a helpful
video and understanding the origins of
Slavs and helped you realize there's
still many unanswered questions we have
about their settlement in Europe this
video is the first at my four-part
series where I will explore the origins
of early Western southern and eastern
Slovak kingdoms hope to see you till
then goodbye